the morning of
the rules committee for Thursday
June thirteenth is for Michael
to order please be advised
an audio and video recording
three for C. is being made
it's also being told a matter
sector please call the roll
Cooley here Cunningham Carillo
flora if Grayson Kamlager-Dove
Maienschein here Mathis
quirk Silva Ramos Rivas
WebSphere number one we have a
quorum -- we have a consent
agenda is our most of the Senate
gender move on this work second
Mister Mathis about second
please call the roll Cooley hi
Cooley aye Cunningham I
Carillo flora Lara I
Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove I
am Maienschein Maienschein aye
Mathis Mathis aye quirk
Silva Ramos Ramos I Rivas
Rivas fireworks -- fourth side
motion motions passed and
additional forces return thank
you very much said her meds